all right let's continue on a very busy
news day um over the weekend there was i
believe a rolling stone story that
started floating around about
car accident victims being turned away
at emergency rooms because they were
filled with people
who took ivermectin and that story was
not true
but because of that confusion
there is now
another story that is a real story that
relates to statements made by the kansas
department of health and the environment
that some people are not taking
seriously which is a real story
um kdhe this is a press release from the
kansas department of health and the
environment okay
this is from a few days ago
kdhe urges kansans not to take
ivermectin for covet 19.
with a rise in calls to poison control
centers and visits to ers
the kansas department of health and
environment is urging kansans not to
take the drug ivermectin unless
prescribed by a physician
then take it exactly as prescribed this
drug is not approved or authorized by
the fda to treat or prevent covet
ivermectin has been approved in humans
to treat specific skin conditions like
rosacea head lice or some parasitic
worms
ivermectin is used in livestock as an
anti-parasite medicine and can be found
in livestock supply centers livestock
drugs are highly concentrated for large
animals and can be highly toxic in
humans can you believe that this is a
statement being put out
by a state health agency in the united
states in 2021
the statement goes on to say
kansans this is a quote from lee norman
dr lee norman secretary of kdhe
kansans should avoid taking medications
intended for animals and should only
take ivermectin as prescribed by their
physician these highly concentrated
doses can cause severe illness and even
death in humans the covet vaccine
remains the most effective way to
prevent prevent covet
and ivermectin overdose includes gi
symptoms such as nausea vomiting and
diarrhea
overdoses are associated with
hypotension meaning very low blood
pressure and neurologic effects such as
decreased consciousness confusion
hallucinations seizures coma and death
ivermectin may intensify the effects of
other drugs that cause central nervous
system depression such as benzos and
barbiturates
the covet vaccine is the safest most
effective way to prevent getting sick
and protect against severe disease i
mean it all it's almost like satire it's
it's unbelievable that this is going on
um they also put out a tweet
saying something very similar kansans
should not take the drug ivermectin
unless prescribed by a physician then
take it exactly as prescribed ivermectin
is not approved or authorized by the fda
to treat or prevent covid
what's really nuts to me
is saying
i won't wear a mask
i won't take an fda approved vaccine as
the pfizer vaccine now is
but i'll take something i bought from a
vet
absent any data that this is good for
coveted humans or in some cases there
are some doctors
who will prescribe you ivermectin um for
covid or
i'll take something
that is a is an off-label use and
off-label use can sometimes be okay but
that has not been shown to actually work
for covid
they're saying i won't trust actual
medical research on what doesn't doesn't
work but i'll trust my so-called
research on ivermectin and they defend
this practice saying you know
the who lists ivermectin as an essential
medication it's been around a long time
it's really cheap and so they're not
making they aren't making money on it so
that's why it's not being prescribed um
but then they when asked for the data
about it being effective for covid they
produce either nothing
or they produce the occasional
uh uh link
to the retracted study with egyptian
data where ivermectin was tested with no
placebo group so i think there's a
couple of important things to understand
number one
it is dystopianly horrible
we are in an idiocracy that the kansas
department of health has to put out such
a statement hey you know what
when you get medications meant for
animals even if it's a medication that
humans sometimes use
the animal concentration is for animals
it's not for humans that is a serious
statement put out by the kansas
department of health
uh and ultimately if people haven't
reasoned their way into a belief it's
very difficult to reason their way out
of it unless you make them understand
they didn't reason their way in and that
means a socratic method of questioning
where you say to people
how did you determine
that this works for covet right
what evidence would change your mind
about that
first you have to get them to realize
the way they got into the belief isn't
very sensible in order to expand their
uh or open them to the idea that they
could change their view
and
we unfortunately we're going to keep
talking about ivermectin uh in this next
segment
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely free
service at privacy.com pacman i've been
using privacy for a little over a year
now you've heard me talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click and the payment is taken out
of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them anytime you want so when you
do this it means you're not going to be
charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance i love using free trials
because i know i won't be charged when
the trial is over if i use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected against data breaches and
identity theft and it's free and like i
said you'll get five dollars to spend
when you sign up at privacy.com
slash pacman